[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
X-Men
x woman c'est-à-dire
en face de X-Men
donc quand je dis X-Men vous me répondez
oui X-Men
sauf que vous êtes des x-peng qui
n'avait pas de super pouvoir
moi je suis là ce soir pour vous
apporter un super pouvoir
si vous deviez avoir un super pouvoir
lequel choisirez-vous
dans les X-Men il y a toutes sortes de
super pouvoirs il y en a qui vole il y
en a même qui ont des fers qui sortent
par les mains il y en a qui sont
transparents il y en a qui qui se
transforment mais quel est le plus
puissant des X-Men
celui qui est le chef quel est son
pouvoir
magnéto c'est ça il y a le pouvoir de de
lire dans les pensées et bien c'est ce
pouvoir là que je vais vous donner ce
soir
ce soir je vous donnerai non seulement
le pouvoir de lire dans mes pensées je
vais vous donner le pouvoir de lire dans
vos propres pensées et ensuite je vais
vous donner le pouvoir de lire dans les
pensées du monde entier
c'est l'ambition que j'ai ce soir
vous voyez là je suis avec ma mère ça
fera Fadiga
c'est moi le petit là je suis tellement
heureux de la retrouver je pensais que
m'avait abandonné ça faisait tellement
tellement longtemps que j'avais vu et là
c'est le jour de bon anniversaire
et je me dis je veux jamais oublier ce
moment je veux jamais que ce moment
s'arrête
et je me dis la vie est tellement si
merveilleux
cette fois-ci c'est la lumière qui
n'arrive pas le son à l'âme est la
lumière est restée
mais d'ailleurs même ça me donne même
plus envie de raconter l'histoire parce
que si c'est comme ça je m'en vais je
raconte plus
c'est faux raconte l'histoire tu sais
bien pourquoi tu as abandonné tu sais
bien pourquoi papa aussi t'as abandonné
qui voudrait d'un avoir comme toi-même
c'est vrai tu as raison je vais raconter
l'histoire en fait je suis né à Paris tu
vois le monsieur qui est derrière moi
c'est pas mon père c'est juste un
monsieur qui est là moi je pensais que
mon père m'avait abandonné parce que
quand je suis né il est parti et donc je
suis au jardin du Luxembourg ma mère
m'envoie là-bas à chaque fois on passe
du temps et à chaque fois que je vois un
monsieur qui est grand je me dis si ça
se trouve peut-être que c'est papa tu
vois
tu sais très bien que c'est pas lui mais
tu fais semblant et puis tu montes
en fait je suis super heureux je passe
du super temps avec ma mère tu vois là
c'est ma mère qui est derrière et là je
suis avec ma meilleure amie c'est pas la
vie de Louga ça on est trop super bien
on s'amuse et c'est trop génial nous on
s'amuse maman travaille
c'est ça tu fais petit étonnes que maman
devait plus de toi à cause de toi il
peut même pas travailler
en fait tu es jaloux c'est faux maman et
moi on va au jardin du Luxembourg chaque
semaine on s'éclate on s'amuse on passe
un super temps et d'ailleurs à chaque
fois que j'y suis c'est tellement bien
qu'on passe des moments merveilleux sauf
qu'aujourd'hui
j'ai l'impression que maman est triste
en fait et je sais même pas pourquoi et
puis moi je m'ennuie un tout petit peu
tu vois
tu sais très bien pourquoi maman est
triste tous les jours tu l'as bassines
avec papa ou papa est où alors tu sais
très bien que tu ne mérites pas d'avoir
papa d'ailleurs qui voudrait d'un enfant
comme toi
ça c'est pas vrai il y a plein de gens
qui voudraient d'enfants comme moi mais
surtout grand-mère ça c'est ma
grand-mère
Fadiga elle elle-même plus que la Lune
le Soleil est toutes les étoiles réunies
quand je suis avec elle je suis
tellement heureux vous pouvez pas
imaginer pour elle je suis un enfant de
la prophétie un enfant spéciale tu vois
ah ouais c'est vrai elle est géniale
mémé et puis tu sais bien que c'est
parce que tu es le meilleur d'abord tu
es le plus beau en plus tu es le plus
intelligent et puis tout le monde sait
que tu es l'enfant de la prophétie mon
gars tu es spécial
ouais tu vois juste spécial je suis
tellement spécial que mes parents ont
décidé que il fallait que j'ai une
famille normale il fallait que j'ai un
papa normal et une maman normale alors
on m'a envoyé vive chez mon oncle lui
c'est mon oncle Lamine Fadiga aka tonton
ministre parce qu'à l'époque il était
ministre de la marine il vivait là juste
à côté à Cocody dans la maison de
Béziers là personne c'est là-bas que
j'ai grandi alors là je suis avec sa
fille c'est comme ma sœur tu vois et
c'est ma famille c'est mon père c'est ma
mère on est heureux d'ailleurs l'autre
jour il a même dit que je pouvais
l'appeler papa tu vois
il a juste dit ça pour te faire plaisir
aux gars tu sais bien que tu seras
jamais comme sa fille et puis ta tête
déteste et tu sais bien que tu le
mérites oh
c'est vrai et même pas trop c'est sûr
bon je suis pas son fils c'est un peu
compliqué mais bon la vie n'est pas si
dure que ça et puis avec elle je suis
dans une maison de riche je vis dans une
vie de riche regarde même le lit il est
assorti au téléphone
c'est pas n'importe qui qui vit ça je
suis heureux on est tous égaux toi tu es
jaloux en fait tu vis pas ma vie c'est
la vie ça
personne ne t'aime personne ne t'aimera
jamais parce que personne ne peut
t'aimer c'est comme ça tant que tu ne
seras pas avec ta vraie maman et ton
vrai papa c'est juste comme ça mon gars
est revenue ma mère est en France elle
faisait ses études elle finissait elle
est rentrée et là je suis avec ma mère
tu vois la fille qui est à côté de moi
là c'est la nounou et le garçon qui a
l'extrême droite c'est mon petit frère
j'ai un petit frère maintenant et là la
fille qui est là juste en bas à gauche
c'est ma petite sœur d'ailleurs ils sont
dans la salle tu vois et la petite
blanche là c'est la fille du voisin nous
on vit à côté des blancs tu vois on vit
à la rivière et
sa fille ses parents on les appelle des
coopérants parce qu'en fait les blancs
ils quittent leur pays ils viennent nous
aider ils sont trop gentils les blancs
franchement c'est trop tard
je t'avais dit que ça allait être pareil
vous n'êtes pas écho tu sais bien que ce
n'est pas ton papa et puis même si tu
habites à côté des blancs toi-même tu es
un petit détresse ville là-bas c'est
mieux que la Suisse de mieux c'est de
partir d'ici aller même dans le monde
ailleurs où vous serez tous égaux
hum c'est vrai et ben tu sais quoi j'ai
réussi le concours d'entrer à l'EMPT
l'école militaire préparatoire technique
Bingerville 45e promotion là-bas tout
est génial je suis avec mes potes on est
trop heureux on est tous égaux et puis
tu sais là-bas franchement l'armée c'est
le vrai bonheur tu me vois là au fond
regarde avec les lunettes là regarde
comment je suis zoo il y a longtemps
[Applaudissements]
que tu es le meilleur c'est toujours dit
ça tu es le plus intelligent tu es le
plus fort d'ailleurs tu seras le plus
aimé tu verras quand tu seras grand tu
verras aux États-Unis et tu reviendras
un héros on a parlé des héros tout à
l'heure tout le monde va hétéro et bien
moi je suis un héros je suis parti aux
États-Unis j'ai eu un diplôme grande
université un boulot même que j'ai un
appartement une bagnole mais si les gars
me voyaient au pays ils allaient être
encaisser je vis la vie de Louga
mon gars ça c'est la réussite ça je suis
audio
menteur pourquoi tu me mens comme ça
c'est vrai tu es un diplômé tu as
l'argent tu possède une belle voiture un
bel appartement mais Tom tu sais que tu
es toujours aussi nul qu'on ne t'aimera
jamais tu n'es rien mon gars tu peux te
la jouer mais nous deux on connaît la
vérité
c'est vrai en fait
moi quand j'étais petit j'avais beaucoup
de Dieu dans ma vie donc j'ai décidé
qu'il faut que je reconnaisse Dieu il
faut que je reparte j'ai décidé de faire
tous les lieux saints tous de Lourdes à
Jérusalem en passant par la Mecque tu
vois là ici je suis à Jérusalem tu
reconnais derrière ça c'est la mosquée
du dôme la mosquée d'Alexa je suis venu
prier ici parce que en fait j'ai une
relation spéciale avec avec Dieu tu vois
tu es jaloux là j'ai même fait le chemin
de croix tu vois ici là ça c'est la
trace de la main de Jésus allez salam
quand il est parti quand il était
crucifié vous connaissez pour ceux qui
ont fait le chemin de croix Jérusalem en
fait si je mets ma la main là-bas je
peux sentir sa présence tu vois parce
que je me sens spécial je suis connecté
à lui tu vois Dieu même ne t'aime pas
tu es jaloux j'ai même fait regarde le
mur de lamentations je me suis dit si je
mets ma prière en haut là-bas j'ai fait
deux mètres 1 m de plus elle peut être
exaucé en priorité tu vois
tu peux toujours rêver
le corps de Jésus
regarde c'est spécial je suis à
l'intérieur j'ai même prié là-bas j'ai
senti la présence du Seigneur tu es un
je le sens en moi tu vois Dieu est
vérité mais toi tu ne fais que mentir
déjà commence par te dire la vérité
là c'est pas faux en fait ce que j'ai
réalisé c'est que tout ça c'est que du
mensonge c'est vrai je me suis mis dans
la tête que oui ouais mon père m'a
abandonné etc et que mon père mon
beau-père ne m'aime pas et que chez mon
oncle c'était pas pareil et que je suis
un enfant martyrisé en réalité quand tu
reviens et que tu apprends et que tu te
dis la vérité tu réalises une chose
c'est que les gens ils font de leur
mieux mon père il m'a jamais abandonné
il a fait de son mieux c'était compliqué
et je pense que je suis même pas sûr que
j'aurais fait mieux à sa place et puis
ma mère elle a fait de son mieux
également mais frère et sœur tout le
monde se bat en fait personne n'est
parfait mais l'idée dans sa tête qu'on
se fait sur les
ce qu'on raconte sur l'histoire qui
s'est passé nos victimisent toujours et
on arrive toujours à se mettre en place
dans une situation dans laquelle c'est
toujours l'autre le fautif on arrive
toujours à se victimiser et à faire en
sorte de croire en nous que nous sommes
le résultat de la méchanceté de l'autre
de sa l'absence de sa non bienveillance
mais lorsqu'on revient sur les
événements qu'on se dit la vérité alors
ça devient différent et là je me suis
rendu compte que la voix qui est dans ma
tête en fait c'est pas moi parce que
quand moi je lis mon livre elle parle
comment ça se fait que je dis mon livre
est bien quand je suis là et je suis
même capable d'avoir des conversations
avec elle je me rends compte que toi que
j'entends là en fait c'est pas moi quoi
j'ai pas le plus
tu peux pas parler tu vas parler comment
et là c'est là où je me rends compte
qu'il faut que j'explique ça aux gens il
faut que j'écrive un livre je vais
écrire un livre où j'expliquais aux gens
quelle est la relation entre eux et leur
ego cette voix qu'ils assimilent à eux
en fait cette voix qu'il pense qu'ils
sont en train de réfléchir et en fait il
réfléchissent pas c'est juste une voix
qui leur dit des choses quand on
réfléchit on réfléchit pour une solution
un problème mais en fait ça cette voix
qui parle d'ailleurs que beaucoup de
gens n'entendent même pas ils ne voient
que le résultat de ces actions
cette voix elle projette des idées mais
en fait c'est juste un leurre il faut
que j'écrive et je sais comment mon
livre va s'appeler le jour montant
tu as dit c'est écrit mais qui va
vouloir te dire maintenant ça c'est pas
un point d'écrivain
c'est ça c'est comme ça qu'elle
fonctionne finalement j'ai rencontré mon
père avec les années et on a on s'est
réconcilié on est devenu des meilleurs
amis du monde il m'a raconté son
histoire et son histoire
elle est comme l'histoire de comme
toutes les histoires tout le monde a des
vies difficiles et tout le monde fait
des choix difficiles il faut pas du tout
rentrer et se mentir il faut apprendre à
se dire la vérité mais en fait ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est comment est-ce
qu'elle fonctionne cette voix parce que
j'ai promis ce soir je vais vous donner
un super pouvoir je vous ai promis de
rentrer dans ma tête vous êtes rentrés
dans ma tête vous avez compris mais je
vais décortiquer pour vous comment elle
fonctionne cette voix parce qu'elle a un
module operandi lorsque tout va mal
lorsqu'on échoue un projet lorsqu'on
échoue quelque chose qu'on veut on veut
absolument réussir voilà ce qu'elle fait
tu sais très bien pourquoi le projet n'a
pas fonctionné les gens sont trop
mauvais ils sont jaloux de toi et puis
pourquoi tu as licencié depuis le
premier jour que tu as commencé ton
travail tu as vu le regard tu as vu les
comportements en fait l'homme moi-même
est mauvais les gens sont mauvais
lorsque tout va bien elle te félicite
elle t'encourage elle te met dans l'idée
que toi tu es le meilleur elle te met
dans la tête que toi tu es meilleur que
les autres lorsque vous venez que vous
ne respectez pas quelqu'un
vous venez vous imaginez que cette
personne vous êtes inférieur soit à
cause de son astuce social soit à cause
de son éducation c'est un mensonge en
quoi seriez-vous supérieur à quelqu'un
parce que vous avez plus d'argent que
lui en quoi seriez-vous supérieur à
quelqu'un parce que vous êtes plus
intelligent ou vous êtes plus éduqué que
lui si ça se trouve il est meilleur bien
dans bien de domaine que vous il parle
des langues que vous ne parlez pas il a
une science que vous ne savez pas il a
une histoire que vous ne connaissez pas
il a un savoir que vous ignorez en fait
nous sommes tous des menteurs cette voie
c'est la voix du mensonge mais c'est un
mensonge permanent lorsque vous venez
que vous respectez un ministre un chef
d'État
un élu plus qu'un planton plus que une
femme de ménage vous êtes un menteur en
quoi ce ministre ce chef d'État s'est
élu serait-il supérieur à cette femme de
ménage en quoi ils sont supérieurs il y
a juste quelqu'un qui a obtenu un poste
et puis quelqu'un qui n'a pas obtenu
mais si ça se trouve Dieu dans Sa
superpuissance peut rendre ce chef
d'État planton
c'est comme ça que la vie et même mieux
il peut faire en sorte que cette femme
de ménage son fils devienne président
ah oui donc il faut arrêter de se mentir
il faut comprendre comment fonctionne
cette voix elle a un fonctionnement
classique dans chacun et chacune de nos
têtes 1
Toto flagelle elle ne te reste pas te
déresponsabilise de elle blâme les
autres et ensuite lorsqu'on va quand
tout va bien elle te fait désirer
désirer et désirer tout en te mettant
dans l'idée que toi tu es meilleur que
les autres oui vous êtes là ici à faire
le rêve la révolution mais avant de
faire le rêve moi je vais vous dire
avant de faire la révolution il faut se
réveiller parce que dans le réveil
il y a rêve et puis il y a éveil il faut
d'abord se réveiller il faut prendre
conscience de cette voie tant que vous
prendrez pas conscience de cette voix
vous n'allez pas pouvoir évoluer mais
avant je vais vous expliquer d'où vient
cette voix parce qu'il faut comprendre
d'où elle vient et pourquoi nous l'avons
tous les livres
du monothéisme s'accordent sur une chose
c'est la Genèse
tous les livres du monothéisme
s'accordent sur le fait que quand Satan
ibise ce qu'on appelle dans l'Islam a
été chassé du Paradis parce qu'il a
refusé de se prosterner devant la
création de l'homme ce qui estimait que
lui avait été créé de feu et que l'homme
avait été créé d'argile il a décidé donc
de tenter par tous les moyens l'homme
mais qu'est-ce qu'il a fait alors là il
y a juste une toute petite différence
entre les musulmans et les chrétiens les
chrétiens disent c'est la femme qui a vu
le fruit défendu et qu'il a donné à
l'homme pour qu'il goûte les musulmans
disent ce sont les deux qui ont été
tentés les deux ils ont mangé toujours
est-il que lorsqu'ils ont mangé ce fruit
défendu tout le monde du pentateur
c'est-à-dire la Torah la Bible au
courant s'accorde sur la même chose la
seconde où ils ont mangé ce fruit ils se
sont couverts
vous rappelez ça veut dire qu'ils ont
pris conscience de leur unité c'est à ce
moment précis qu'ils ont pris conscience
de leur moi et le fruit défendu
qu'est-ce qui représentait l'arbre de la
connaissance en réalité ce mois n'est
notre que ce n'est rien d'autre que la
tentation cette voie qui est en vous en
réalité ce n'est pas vous
ce n'est pas vous elle a juste votre
voix mais ce n'est pas vous et ceux qui
ne l'entendent pas mais qui voit juste
le résultat de ces suggestions c'est à
dire que eux ils n'entendent même plus
eux ils se voient juste dans une
Mercedes avec une belle Go pavanante
devant leurs ennemis ils se voient juste
au sommet de la montagne comme on dit
meilleur employé avec les honneurs avec
l'argent et le pouvoir ou il se voit
juste en train de tomber pendant qu'ils
font une présentation ici à TEDx parce
qu'ils ont tellement peur de se
présenter devant les gens tout ça c'est
juste le fruit d'une imagination et
cette imagination là est le fruit de
cette égo là ce n'est pas vous alors je
vais vous dire pour terminer ici et vous
donner le plein pouvoir que je suis
censé vous donner puisque je vous ai
permis de rentrer dans votre tête dans
la mienne maintenant je vais vous
permettre de rentrer dans la tête de
tout le monde
pour se faire on va conjuguer ensemble
menteur je suis un menteur je suis un
menteur tu es un menteur
il est un menteur avec moi nous sommes
des menteurs vous êtes des menteurs il
ou elles sont des menteurs nous sommes
tous des menteurs rappelez-vous ça à
tout moment et sachez que l'humilité
précède la gloire doit
[Applaudissements]